mean i guess it would be great if it
could just
get it yeah right no that's the whole
point of what you're saying right it's
the messaging between the two that's
right that keeps the balance yeah but
chuck that's another point of failure a
possible failure in the human body
that's because you're looking at it from
the standpoint of some guy who shoots
crap into space
[Music]
this is star talk sports edition neil
degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist and co-host of this
podcast i got with me my two other
co-hosts chuck nice chuck how are you
doing man what's happening neil i'm hot
okay
professionals yeah getting well it's
summertime let it be no i was i was
actually just complimenting myself neil
no
i'm glad you feel that way about
yourself okay
this is the first step towards recovery
yes
professional stand-up comedian we love
you here and i love you as my co-host so
we also have the only one who gives this
podcast its authenticity is gary
o'reilly former soccer pro gary always
good to have you oh his pleasure's mine
neil thank you
also professional sports commentators
yes which i only learned very late
in doing that distracted by your soccer
talent and i was not thinking of you in
any other way just one and plus there's
a wiki page on you in case people do
want to see your legs
back in the day
my boy got his soccer wikipedia that's
cool boy i tell
so what we're going to talk about today
is
the endocrine system oh my gosh we are
long overdue for a show on this subject
i remember in high school learning about
biology you know there's a heart and a
liver and lungs and all that you have
skin and blood and then i learned about
the endocrine systems like oh my gosh
there's like we don't just have stuff in
our body we have chemistry going on in
our body and so obviously none of us
have this expertise we had to reach for
it as we always do and i think we always
do really well and gary so set up the
table here what are you oh with pleasure
um so we we started this show by asking
a simple question in a production
meeting how do anabolic steroids work in
the human body and then as you were just
saying in the human body you've got a
variety of systems a digestive system
respiratory system
immune system and we know pretty much
all about them
but the chances are we don't really know
a lot about the endocrine system
what it does now it does its thing uh
what happens if it goes wrong
can we tweak it for our own good say
with anabolic steroids and you know how
can we make that work and from that
initial question we've got a whole load
of wow
and you know right so when you say tweak
it you mean how can we game it yeah for
our own that's what you really mean
this is this is the element of like you
know okay
but everyone's looking for advantage
it's a competitive world sport's
competitive by nature so what if
but we needed to know more about how the
whole structure works
and uh you know that's the takeoff point
for this show um of course we needed an
expert and i'm pleased we've found this
young this young gentleman dr anakit
siddhay from john hopkins medicine where
he is program director for endocrinology
and metabolism fellowship he's also
associate professor of medicine an
expert in cystic fibrosis related
endocrine disorders so having said all
of that let's meet the good doctor
hello
aniket welcome to star trek well thank
you very much neil thank you all of you
for having me i'm excited to be part of
this conversation and so glad to hear
you all are interested in the endocrine
system
oh my gosh and you're so young oh my god
when i went for my job this weekend i
didn't feel that young
oh
don't worry oh you know if you're an
expert on the endocrine system you
should never feel any way that you
shouldn't
i'm thinking that's just me i don't know
so could ellis could you just start us
off i i want our audience to be just as
mind-blown as i was when i first learned
what the endocrine system does so you
just give us like a you know a three
minute overview sure i know that's not
much time
you can fit it in i'm sure you're only
all of your academic uh findings and
career that's right right right in 90
seconds yeah so what do you have you
know in a way
it is a system by which one part of the
body talks to the other but to maintain
balance
and the way it does this is by the
secretion of hormones and the definition
of a hormone is pretty simple it's a
substance that's secreted in one part of
the body
and it's a chemical it's a chemical it's
called something it's a chemical
and
it goes to another part of the body
and tells that part of the body what to
do but what's really important about the
endocrine system is that they're in
almost all of the hormones
there is a feedback loop that involves
control
and that's probably what helps it
maintain balance in the body so all of
the hormonal systems have this sort of
we call it homeostasis or balance effect
on whatever it is that they're supposed
to be regulating
um
and so like for if i could give an
example would that be okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah totally because i'll give the
example of insulin because i think a lot
of people know about insulin and
diabetes and blood glucose
so
insulin is the hormone that helps
maintain blood glucose levels in a very
very narrow range uh and the way it does
this is super interesting so etiquette
that glucose that's just one of the
sugars right they all end in ose last i
checked that's right that's absolutely
correct like fructose and mannose and
galactose
sucrose galactose
lactose you should love that one neil
oh by the way it's not an accident that
the
milky way galaxy the very word galaxy uh
comes from its reference to
milk and the milky way and
lactose and all this yeah it's very
related from the latin very nice and of
course roman times but ancient rome but
go on this is not about astronomy right
all right yeah so glucose actually
stimulates the pancreas to make insulin
so as the glucose levels rise the
pancreas has this mechanism of
increasing the amount of insulin that's
secreted and then that insulin goes to
muscle and fat predominantly but other
tissues as well
and it tells those tissues to take up
the glucose from the bloodstream thereby
returning the glucose back down to the
normal range
as the glucose comes down the insulin
levels come down as well so you can see
it's this mechanism by which the glucose
is the stimulator the insulin goes up
once the glucose comes back down the
insulin comes back down
what you're saying is the pancreas
doesn't know better because if it did
you wouldn't have all these extra
overhead steps for all this to to work
yeah i mean i guess it would be great if
it could just
get it yeah right no that's the whole
point of what you're saying right it's
it's the messaging between the two
that's right that keeps the balance yeah
but chuck that's another point of
failure of possible failure in the human
body that's because you're looking at it
from the standpoint of some guy who
shoots crap into space
if we have points of failure
i want to know about it i want to reduce
them as much as possible and you're
telling me you have an endocrine system
that tells something else what chemical
to put in and how to take it out and
that's too many people in the command
chain well you know of course you know
when this system fails we get diabetes
to your point about points of failure
yeah all right so doctor is there a
command center is there some ultimate
control
center for all of this endocrine system
or is it systems within systems that
manage each other or can they cross out
into other systems um
so they can definitely cross talk with
other systems but in terms of a command
center there happens to be one organ
that controls multiple different
endocrine systems
and the brain yes just below the brain
is the pituitary and pituitary gland
unit over there controls
um how your body makes stress steroids
that help you respond to stress like
cortisol right it helps you resp
make the sex steroids uh so testosterone
yep there you go yeah um and
well just for you chuck of course
for all of those who have kids and want
them to grow it helps regulate the
growth hormone system so there is one
gland that happens to control multiple
different systems so what does the
hypothalamus do oh it's a super super
question so the hypothalamus sits above
the pituitary the hypothalamus sense in
the brain
and it sends the signals down to the
pituitary
to make their hormones so okay sort of
told you you see yeah you see you know
what i'm starting to agree with neil
there
this is a house of cards all right so
we've got we've got all these little
moving parts that are command centers
but yeah
are there different types of cell
signaling
that take place or is it all one mode or
does it come with a variety of settings
so each your so this gets to how do
hormones actually act
um and they all act by interacting with
a receptor
and that receptor either
you know goes into dna and regulates
genes and i know you guys have had
people come and talk about genes and
gene expression
or that receptor helps change
predominantly how proteins work and so
they all interact with specific
receptors and that's how you maintain
specificity in each system so the
insulin so
do old wasp families in the united
states have blue jeans
there's no that's not a mandatory answer
there
sorry that was it's so much better than
wranglers
[Music]
what is epigenome because you talked
about messaging for dna so what is
epigenome and epigenome communication
sure
so the gene is a code to make proteins
um but
you know why should a particular gene be
on or off it turns out that our genome
can have marks on it there are other
systems that can say hey you know what i
want this gene to be turned off
and they mark the genome in a certain
way so that genes can be turned on or
off
and so
there are many different types of these
marks but
there are signatures for genes that are
on versus off and that is often found in
the epigenome
uh and so hormones for example can
regulate that and by the way i etiquette
the in my when i was in college long ago
i took a computer science class where we
learned about the role of the dip
switches
on the on the backs of the computers
where you can change certain modes of
operation and that became a very useful
reference when people were talking about
gene expression for about like five
years until those computers weren't
around anymore but when you say turning
them on and off i think of the the back
of the computer where you had these
switches
and you'd manipulate them but you had to
know what you were doing
right
does this epigenome
become affected by
environmental
aspects and influences such as your
environment pollutants and things
yeah i think that there is you know sort
of growing interest in that um
and
um those types of studies
uh have been done sort of in cells right
but you know then you have to take the
next step of saying okay let's expose
lots of people to a pollutant and then
look at the epigenome and the answer is
yeah or not
or yeah right
if you want to connect an ethical study
yes thank you and
and then see but you these occur
naturally right because there are flight
attendants who are exposed to smoke for
example and other people who are not and
so the day in the day in the day in the
day not anymore not anymore
and so you can then look and look at
their genomes and
and see if they their epigenetic changes
occur and there's a lot of evidence that
that has occurred just when you mention
the pituitary gland i'm reminded that
some of the
the
the
physical conditions that make people
short or very extremely tall
directly
come out of failures of the
of the pituitary gland yeah but i i
heard the term maybe we don't say it
anymore pituitary giant yeah that's
still a term yeah uh
there's a term gigantism yeah yeah right
uh and that's when there's too much
growth hormone right in the when kids
are growing and then they grow up to be
very very very tall
um but you can also have extra growth
hormone made
after people start growing right and
then they don't get taller but other
parts of their bodies grow so
they
you know they have jaws that are a
little bit bigger their hands become
kind of wide barry bonds
[Laughter]
he was a different kind of big yeah
that's a different that's a difference
he was from another planet that's a
little human growth we'll save that for
section three yeah okay go back to the
sound signaling modes you know you said
about the computer switch on the back
nail what i mean are the notes uh
neuroendocrine and autocrine modes for
signaling doctor
yeah so what that refers to is
neuroendocrine is simply like my hypo
the hypothalamus and the pituitary make
a hormone they go to for example the
adrenal gland tell it to make more
cortisol
right but autocrine is within a
single sort of tissue system where
a cell makes
a signal
let's call it a growth factor for
example and it'll go next door to a cell
so it doesn't have to enter the
bloodstream and travel
um to some other place
um entering the bloodstream and
traveling is like the traditional
definition of a hormone
but
autocrine is just you know talking to
your neighbor
and
and judging them to do something a
little different so shopping local right
yeah
yeah yeah we got to end this segment but
when we come back uh doctor i want to
talk about all the ways that the
endocrine system can fail us okay right
when it's working you know nobody says
anything right you're just a quote
normal human being yeah and you're a
doctor specializing in occasions where
this that system fails yeah
make sure we spend a whole segment on
that this is star talk sports edition
we'll be right back
we're back star talk sports edition an
entire episode on the endocrine system
your hormones long overdue for a topic
of interest on this show of course i got
chuck and gary and our special guest
today is dr anakit siddale
who is an associate professor of
medicine johns hopkins university excuse
me the johns hopkins university i think
they prefer
uh specializing in endocrinology an
expert in cystic fibrosis
and
also diabetes i think is that right
we'll learn more about that in a minute
but uh who better to keep us on this
journey and so let me uh jump back in
so here we have a system of
chemistry basically and and annika i
don't know if you know this but some of
my best friends are made of chemicals
okay don't don't tell anybody
some of my best friends actually do
chemicals
so you we we spent the first segment
describing the the the glory and the
majesty of our endocrine system but i
kept thinking about it from a systems
engineering point of view because when
you launch something into space
everything has to work and you want to
reduce the number of nodes
of failure
and from your description
it sounds like there are multiple
handoffs chemical handoffs from one
location to another to another in order
to regulate this body which sounds to me
like we have high susceptibility to
failure so what can you tell us about
what happens when our hormones go bad
yeah yeah you're right there are
different points of failure and there
are many many diseases many common
diseases that are due to disruptions to
the endocrine system probably the best
known as diabetes okay um yep yeah i
mean not good diabetes that's bad but
good you're going to talk about it yeah
good we're going to understand it and
diabetes is simply means that there's a
lot of sweet
tasting stuff flowing through your
system that's what diabetes mellitus
means
and that means your blood glucose is too
high one of the sugars that we talked
about and
really the reason that happens is
because people can't make enough insulin
and um you know depending on what type
of diabetes you have
uh the reason for that could be
different but the bottom line is there's
just not enough insulin being made for
your body's needs when there's not
enough insulin there's not that signal
that tells the glucose hey go from the
bloodstream into the muscle or into the
fat right or very interestingly insulin
also tells the liver
to stop making sugar so that's another
way in which insulin acts but all of
these things you can see
if there's not enough insulin the blood
glucose stays high
and in the same way there are many other
hormonal systems another common one is
the thyroid system we like the thyroid
gland because you can actually feel it
it sits right on top of your trachea and
so it's a gland that you can actually
feel just like the other gland you can
feel which is your testes so the thyroid
if the thyroid is damaged you don't make
enough thyroid hormone and thyroid
hormone i like to describe as
it kind of tells every cell in the body
how fast to run the furnace so if you
don't make enough thyroid hormone you
feel cold you feel sluggish you can't
think quite as fast you get constipated
your skin becomes super dry
and so that's an example of when you
don't make enough but of thyroid hormone
but you can also have the reverse
you can actually make too much of a
hormone um and when you make too much
thyroid hormone for example it's all the
opposite people feel hot they sweat they
can't sleep they actually feel
tremendous or shaky even
their hearts might race and so that's an
example of you know when you have
deficient or excess thyroid hormone um
we mentioned gigantism in the previous
segment and that would be an example of
having too much growth hormone
a real dangerous one is when you don't
make enough cortisol because you need
cortisol it's like a stress response
like
when when you're stressed you need to
make cortisol and if you can't then your
blood pressure can't respond
uh your immune system you know can't
respond and you know you can even die if
you don't have enough is there something
called hypocotylosis
hypercautism
yeah yeah yeah that is in fact not
enough cortisol hype okay cortisol
there's hypo and hyper there's hypo and
hyper yeah it's too much hypo is not
enough you got it yeah and when you have
hyper it's a whole other set of problems
uh you know
that that people get it
and this is just a great example of like
how many different systems one hormone
can affect so if you take
hypercortisolism people can get diabetes
their skin gets very fragile right um
and they can bruise really easily
they can get fractures because it makes
the bones thin and you can't absorb
calcium properly from your gut to help
mineralize the bone so lots of different
systems get affected by one hormone so
on the subject of words
on the subject of words you know we have
the word hyperbole where you're going a
little too far we should invent the word
hyperbole where you're not
that you see that just sounds like you
can't say hyperbole
hypothesis
[Laughter]
you're not exaggerating enough right
you're under selling what you i thought
that's what english people do yeah yeah
the understatement you're getting blamed
again
a master of hyperbole i'm gonna invent
that word boy's about as sharp as a
bowling ball always using hyperbole
so gary take us back to sports here how
do you wait
that's the goal
because i just want to talk about what
you or what you just said doc yeah
so all these things you just pointed out
a lot of times i read these articles
where it says that they're exacerbated
by belly fat
so what what does that have to do with
anything the fact that i'm carrying all
this subcutaneous fat yeah yeah
it turns out that fat is not some inert
depo for storage of fat you know like
our fat tissue it is a very active organ
almost
and it makes in inflammatory signals
and um those inflammatory signals can go
around your body and make your pancreas
not work as well make your muscle not
take up glucose they can make your the
blood vessels you know a little reactive
and make you more prone to
cardiovascular disease so the fat is
secreting lots of signals that can be
can be bad for you
such as what puts you at risk for that
other kind of diabetes correct in later
life that's right if you're overweight
as i understood it yep you as you get
more fat your body becomes more
resistant to insulin
now
you know if your pancreas can still deal
with that resistance you don't get
diabetes but you know obviously there's
a lot of people whose bodies can't react
uh and they get diabetes as a result
right right okay okay so gary put us
back on track here where are we taking
this um
the body produces its own steroids
yes um
but what happens if production starts
to go up too far or go down too low
and if we wanted to introduce
exterior steroids
into the system
how did they interact how do they play
with the endocrine system so too much
natural too low and then the the
introduction of exterior extension
we didn't hear officially yet what a
steroid is yeah yeah if you can just
give a minute on that please sure sure
so the steroid hormones are a class of
hormones and they basically their their
backbone is cholesterol
so they all have cholesterol that is
used to make these hormones so cortisol
is a steroid hormone
and that is the stress hormone i just
talked to you about testosterone is a
steroid hormone that's what's really
responsible for
males being males
and estradiol which is the female sex
steroid is a steroid hormone so it's a
class of hormones so when people say
steroids they could mean different
things but from you know we're talking
about sports i'm thinking you're talking
about
androgenic
steroids yeah that is right and that's
the ones you're talking about and
the reason
um
for that people obviously have a lot of
interest in these is because
androgens have two different effects
that are linked they
help you know us males look like males
uh but
they also have this anabolic effect on
muscle uh and they
people's muscles get bigger and i think
we all know what those folks look like
yeah so
you know
interestingly there are
really rare rare situations where
somebody might make too much of a sex
steroid um tell me about it yeah
um but most of it
you know unless you are
you know
uh a comedian on a talk show radio
you know uh most of them are they're
taking those
those androgenic steroids from outside
uh in one way or the other to help
enhance performance
[Music]
so do
do women also make testosterone
they do in a very very very small amount
then how do they make it
uh so
that is very interesting um
estradiol which is the female sex
steroid is actually made from
testosterone
oh yeah so yeah i was about to ask oh
wait that's why that's why when men get
like really fat they stop producing as
much testosterone and they start growing
boobs
no they're they're called moobs oh
that's right
oh yeah so
it turns out that you need an enzyme to
convert that testosterone to estradiol
and when you're
more fat then you have more of that
enzyme and so you make more estradiol
for that right
and so there's this balance between
testosterone and estradiol that gets a
little flipped and once that happens men
can get breast develop
everybody kind of defaults to the
anabolic steroids yeah um but is there
another way
that
you could get a boost similar kind of
boost in performance
from the endocrine system without using
anabolic steroid instead of an external
acceleration
why not
something that prompts your body to do
it on its own or prompts your body to
fall out of balance so that you get all
muscle-like well wait gary it's so
so
the
the doping
rules yeah do they specifically say you
can't put a chemical from outside your
body inside your body but if i can do
something inside my body that gives me
all of the hormones of the steroids that
i want and would have added to me but i
made it myself is that then legal um
there is a gray area because you know
there's always a gray area yeah quesa
mania the the female middle distance
runner has a higher natural level of
testosterone
they're going ape over this they really
are going nuts as to what to do or not
to do yeah and so i mean and the other
thing is if if you remember we did a
show on
horses and horsepower yeah and then we
we were introduced to the fact that the
horse's spleen can produce a rush of red
blood cells highly oxygenated red blood
cells that help an initial burst of
speed for the horse in that racehorse
and i'm just wondering do we have
similar facilities
for ourselves
to be able to do that and we're not
quite
thinking that this could be something to
use yeah can i sit in a lotus position
and increase my steroid
just by just by thinking it all right to
have that power over body well
you know i think that one of the things
that i think we've been talking about is
that these hormonal systems are acting
in the background and we're not even
aware that they're acting yeah right but
there are for example
like if you're stressed
you're not going to make that much
testosterone so any amount of stress is
going to reduce your testosterone to to
the extent that that testosterone is
important for maintaining
your muscle mass for example
then that's going to affect your
performance uh for example you know so
you know you would be i guess it would
be an indirect way of making sure that
you're making the optimal amount of
of in this case testosterone but that
would be true for potentially any any
other
system
um
but in terms of sort of natural ways of
of boosting hormone production so
for example
in the
in in the testosterone system
you know if for example you have reduced
sexual activity
you will then have reduced slowly reduce
production of testosterone there's
nothing that you could do to boost it
that
you know you wouldn't you'd have to have
a control mechanism and i think that's
what we're lacking so is there a natural
way for me to boost testosterone but not
let it be too high because you know i
mean you need a knob attached to your
body where your body doesn't shut down
the high level that it's trained to do
but the body already has the knob so
right the hypothalamic pituitary system
is that knob it doesn't let you make too
much or too little
so now what about uh gaining muscle
because you always
anybody who gains muscle they're like
the best way to increase your
testosterone is to build muscle because
your body says i got to have more
testosterone is that real or is that
like something that these these
companies do to get you to buy their
little medical supplements yeah
metabolic supplement companies
not
investigated or approved by the fda yeah
yeah i mean you know i'm sure all of you
know that you know the the use of
um everybody's looking for
this magic bullet to increase vitality
let's call it that for lack of a word um
yeah and
with that there's was this huge surge in
even high school kids using
um anabolic steroids in the late 90s and
2000s
um yeah to try and get bigger for either
sports or just even how they looked
um but even prescriptions for
testosterone have gone up from
the late 90s it was like 18 million
dollars worth and now it's like 18
billion dollars worth oh my god
this is big big business
big business in my opinion you should
use testosterone when someone has a bona
fide organic reason for not making
testosterone like for example you had a
pituitary tumor and it got taken out but
now you can't make the hormones that
help you make testosterone okay but i'm
bombarded with commercials that say at
your age you have lower testosterone
right yes and the body is insulin it's
low t
low teeth okay
wait so so if that's correct
then
you are supplementing the testosterone
that you once had in your older age
right
yeah and this this has been long known
this natural decline in testosterone
that occurs in men at
a relatively slow rate compared to women
who go under menopause and then their
fall in estradiol is really very
dramatic uh in the first year after
menopause but amen it's this slow
decline and this is like a question
right like this is just a natural thing
that happens
maybe there's a reason that this natural
thing happens well death is natural too
but that doesn't mean i have to embrace
it
let's be clear about it i'm not racing
towards it
that's right they'll say nature would
have it that way and so should you no
all right so doctor is it now you and
you've talked about an amazing bump in
the sale of testosterone prescription
drug
is it
not just performance enhancement or
muscle growth
but
people are using it as an anti-aging
supplement yeah and that's and it's
because now it's become a fashionable
trend let's put a pin in that until the
third segment where i want to get
more into
what role these hormones are playing on
what it is to be male or female in the
first place
we're back starcall sports edition i've
got a professional endocrinologist
in the house
in the zoom house i guess we'll call it
that dr anakit siddhaya
telling us all about hormones and what
we
what we thought we knew and more stuff
we didn't know we didn't know
so let me introduce this
segment this third and final segment by
asking
uh you described
categories or hormones that make us
female that make us male
biologically and now we are living in a
world where trans athletes
are are are striving to be recognized
in sports
in a category in a sex category
different from what they were assigned
at birth
and so
what what does your community say and
think about this
because i to the extent that i thought
about it not that i have any expertise
but i
like to think of myself as rational and
thoughtful that maybe
we no longer contest athletes by sex
men against men women against women you
have categories of hormones
hormones how much
female hormone do you have relative to
male hormones and those go into
categories they just compete in your
hormone category and then who cares
whether you're male or female at that
point so what what
yeah yeah
hormonal weight class yes basically yeah
because i used to wrestle we had 10
freaking weight classes right because
you know you can't pit people vastly
different weights against each other and
you still want to have an interesting
contest all right so i can look at the
118 pound wrestlers it'll be just as
interesting as the 250 pound wrestlers
because they're matched
and why do we any of us watch sports
it's for the match-up it's for the
contest it's for the suspense of not
knowing who is going to win the most
boring super bowl ever is a blowout okay
the advertisers hate it when the
the team is winning you know 35 to six
all right because no one watches the ads
at that point
so unless it's the eagles
okay
can't do it mr philadelphia native uh so
uh doctor said hey what tell me um
what's your reaction to what i said and
what how do you guys feel in general
yeah i mean i think so at a very basic
level we know that testosterone can
increase muscle mass
and of anybody
of anybody that's right
and
power the power output of that muscle
so i think that that's something that
society has to contend with i think your
suggestion is very interesting and
creative like could we have just like
you have age categories or weight
categories yeah did you have a
testosterone level category and i think
that
you know my initial reaction was like
wow that'd be a great solution but then
the problem is that the normal range of
testosterone is extremely wide
um
and you know it goes from like 300 to
like
1200 in the units that we typically use
to measure and
one person could be at 900 and that's
normal for them and another person could
be at 400 and that's normal for them
and
so i don't think that we have the
measurements sophisticated enough to
kind of do that type of categorization
because wait but what you can well they
take blood samples and urine samples
every day
during contest so it's not like we don't
have access to the chemistry of your
body in very important athletic events
what i would ask is if your natural
testosterone is 800 and minus 400
can i beat you in an event
can't if we are otherwise equal but our
testosterone levels are different are we
really otherwise equal because
because you know what what is what is
professional sports if not i will do
everything i can to gain an advantage
over my competitors i will train at high
altitude i will i will do breathing
exercises i will take all my vitamins i
will eat three squares i will get a full
night's sleep i'll carbo-load if i have
to all of these are steps i'm taking to
give me an advantage beyond my pure
genetics but but if you're relating this
just to um a genderized
aspect
then what i think the doctor is saying
is
inside of that normal parameter you're
going to find that men are pretty much
going to be much larger than women and
even if you have a woman who
is um
who is superior testosterone who has
superior testosterone then her
counterparts she's probably still going
to fall at the very low end of a man
physically in terms of the physicality
yeah wait wait wait i thought we're
talking about hormones here because yes
their people are bigger than other
people right and so big people play
football all right i'm not saying oh my
gosh that's not fair you had a genetic
advantage because you're 300 pounds and
i'm 150 pounds no they play football and
i pay to watch them and they entertain
me right so we shouldn't walk into this
saying oh my gosh some people have
genetics that make them better at this
you know uh uh michael phelps does he
have sloppy her feet and big feet that
give him extra propeller blades when
he's swimming okay are we saying
disqualify him because of this no all
right rather than just narrowly pinpoint
testosterone doctor are there other
hormones that we could sort of bundle in
together to then use
as categorization through as well as
weight and physicality wait wait wait
wait wait gary he didn't answer my
question yet because okay chuck butt in
wait
yeah
and get to what you said gary because
that's important i'm simply asking
yeah in a race of any kind in a contest
of any kind of involves strength uh uh
agility of the things that the
testosterone well not agility but
strength certainly the testosterone and
speed the testosterone may give you
if you checked everyone's testosterone
level
in a race
would it be ordered by how much
testosterone they had
statistically
um that's a good question and i think
the answer is no if 800 is normal for
you and 400 is normal for me can i beat
you at an event yes because if i well
okay so here's the deal
step so so no so what you're saying
makes perfect sense if it's if it's a
hormonal weight class and you're able to
categorize people by uh their
testosterone number yeah and then you
just test everybody and that's your
weight class it's a weight class right
now now now it's like all right how hard
did i train it's like what is my
strategy it's like all these other
factors right because we are equally
matched when it comes to our hormonal
state
you're leveling the playing field i just
i just want to i just want to indirect
one thing that you know
the testosterone
like i said 400 could be normal for me
800 could be normal for neal right
um and then we're both normal so that's
where i think your difficulty would be
coming and coming of class so
you know
how would you make a category 200 to 400
is one category four no it'll take some
effort yes somebody's had to do some
research on this but that's why why i
mean why not if that's the direction
we're going so
yeah you'll find people actually
depressing their testosterone numbers
so they could be the superior athlete in
the lower weight class yeah so
are there other hormones
doctor that we could
as i said bundle into the testosterone
group to then
even better
equate
the playing field and level it out
and by the way what what is the pipeline
for that it's kids in school wanting to
be athletes right and
uh how do you how does your
your profession
uh interact with the entire pipeline of
people who
who need hormone therapy or or endocrine
therapy yeah yeah yeah yeah i guess
there's sort of two questions there
one is i
i think that because the purpose of the
hormone system is to maintain balance
right right i think that's where this
difficulty in finding this hormonal
weight class will be
um because what is going to be balance
in me is not exactly balance in you so i
i think that
people are always trying to develop
prediction tools and
putting in more pieces into that
prediction tools um but i think it would
be a a big stretch to come up with some
kind of multi-hormonal
um
categorization of people to level the
playing field
in terms of
where we
our field interacts i think probably the
biggest place is
in
persons who have diabetes you mentioned
that as like the number one endocrine
failure of the body yeah yeah yeah i
mean certainly an endocrinologist in
practice we take care of patients with
diabetes it's the bulk of our practice
but in terms of
kids who are participating in sports
those people who also have diabetes
it's a big challenge for them
and
you know really watching them overcome
those hurdles is really it's really kind
of inspiring to be very honest that
despite having this chronic illness
which requires a lot of work on their
part to help manage themselves they
still take parent reports and we try and
help do it so that they can do it in a
safe way
and you know talking about diabetes
diabetes is a deficiency of insulin and
so we treat it by giving back insulin to
the patient the problem is that our ways
of giving back insulin
um don't have the advantages that the
body has remember i told you about that
link between how glucose stimulates
insulin insulin goes up and then once
glucose comes down insulin comes down
but when we ask a patient to take an
injection of insulin
we can't take it back so even when the
glucose comes down that insulin is still
there so an athlete so
normally when people start working out
their glucose levels fall just a little
bit and their insulin levels fall as
well normally speaking so i hadn't fully
appreciated that because as my sugar
levels go up and down my body goes in
and regulates it but if i don't have the
ability to regulate it and i in put in
the insulin that's a fixed amount of
insulin and so that's why the diabetic
people
always have to manage their sugar intake
in the way none of the rest of us do
yeah that's it
it's an amazing amount of work that is
there a technological solution to this
going yeah i'm glad you brought it up
you know yeah
both technological and biological
solutions you know that in our field
we're just super excited about both
potentially
um so we have continuous glucose
monitors so these are devices that
people wear on their body and they have
little catheters that dangle
just beneath the skin and they're
sampling that fluid every five minutes
and measuring the glucose it turns out
that fluid's glucose
mirrors the blood glucose pretty closely
and the device companies have come up
with now this glucose information can be
transmitted to an insulin pump right and
the insulin pump is delivering insulin
in sort of little bits at a time
and now these insulin pumps can adjust
the amount of insulin that they deliver
based on the glucose information just as
your body would have done yeah
that whole it's like a pacemaker for for
instance yeah yeah very good yeah micro
dose right because i used to have a
teammate of mine back in the day gary
mabar who was an exceptional footballer
went to the very very top of the game
in english football he would have to go
away pop a needle in his hip
jump all this insulin into his body but
now you're saying
this can be kind of micro dosed and
regulated so you've not got too much in
your system after you've your glucose
levels have dropped that's right so
you know now that these devices are
really just coming on the market in a
big way in the last two three years
people are going to learn to use them
more effectively and there are
strategies that you know people who
study exercise and type 1 diabetes that
we
tell patients so that they can manage
their glucose better
and that's important both for safety you
know you obviously don't want to have a
low glucose in the middle of a
workout or a middle of a game but also
performance you know when people's
glucoses are riding high for a long
period of time guess what that glucose
in the bloodstream is not doing their
muscle any benefit
so
now we're really optimistic because it's
in their bloodstream that's right and
not in their muscle uh to help them
so these devices i think are going to
make it easier for
you know
people and kids to participate in sports
in a more safe way then of course
there's these biological solutions you
know it was in in the news recently
about a stem cell-based treatment which
is basically a little pancreas in a in a
capsule let's call it that
where people get injected with these
cells and these cells can respond to
glucose in the bloodstream the way the
body would have and of course
you know maybe that is going to take a
few years to
to come to fruition for a large scale
but these trials are ongoing in humans
right now
so
this is all very hopeful and you're like
like we all agreed you were young and so
you're going to be in this and you're
going to watch this field
burgeon
in so many ways this is very fascinating
before we close i want to ask i guess
what would be an ethical question
all right we're so busy defining what is
normal in this world you know are you
the normal height the normal weight are
your organs functioning the way
the average organ should
and then you get some variation in that
and the urge is to say that's abnormal
there's an entire tv show on cable that
follows a family with dwarfism
all right i think that's what it's
called but
they're called little people right with
the shortened long bones
colloquially they're little people and
everything in their life is made little
to accommodate their lives and they're
getting along just fine
so who are you as an endocrinologist to
say that they are ab-normal
i think that's a good question yeah any
time you know a lot of pediatric
endocrinologists obviously uh are often
asked to see
people who have we say short stature
is the way we say it and
um
you know normal and abnormal are usually
defined based on some population-based
data
and and to be homosexual was considered
abnormal
in the psychiatric journals until 1987
last i remembered reading about this and
so
so this is clearly a cultural force that
needs to operate on top of this whatev
on top of whatever statistics you're
finding in the population yeah and i
think the better way to think about all
this always is this healthier and
healthy
is this
stature that is
lower than the population norms is it
healthier and healthy and for example
the story that you just described
it
is not unhealthy evidently it doesn't
have any negative health consequences we
as doctors we want to make sure that
okay does
these people who maybe have short
stature are they at increased risk of
fracture 20 30 years down the road or
are they increased risk of heart disease
20 30 years down there or maybe not
maybe they're actually protected so we
always would then want to take this what
we're seeing and seeing is there
something unhealthier
or maybe some advantage to that and i
think you're right i think we have to be
very careful about the labels we put on
on people um
and i think our field as all fields in
medicine
um are becoming more sensitive to that
okay all right so there's some there's
some hope but this is in the broader
subject of inclusion really
what category that would come under all
right we got to land that plane this has
been star talk sports edition all about
endocrinology neil degrasse tyson here
your personal astrophysicist keeping up
[Music]